今日はこちらしていいですまた言葉の勉強についての話ですけれども
言葉の勉強はですねまず言葉の勉強というのは日本語では言葉
のその意味がまあいい部というと line グッズでしょ
しかし言葉の意味もワール単語といいにもパワーですよ一つの言葉ねっ
であのそれは非常にいいと思うんですよ
なぜかというと
言葉位は言語の勉強はまず
単語
合意の
勉強です
やはり
20各国語も勉強
してありますから北
やはりその合意のスジュどれだけの単語
どれだけの言葉 war 5しているかによって
レベルが大体決まります
あのー
ではじゃあその言葉を知ってるって言うかその単語を知ってるっていうのはどういう
意味ですか
ある人はねそのあるウェイ
単語
その視点というさの定義がそれが使えるというあの意味をするというふうに思ってます
僕はそれがそうは思わないんです
あのレイクではねでリンクを作ったときも僕はその一番簡単な
その
誰かのその言葉のその水準をその評価するには一番簡単
一番親父一番その正確なその測り方は合意ですどれだけの単語を知ってるかと
だがしかしこの知っているかというのがあくまであの
どこそこのコンテクストの中でこの単木を単語を見ればわかる
今の受身たし分かりますわかる
使えるというその日家寄せはないです
そのこの言葉してるという事を言うにはですね
使えるという意味はないですなぜかというと
自分の言葉じゃ僕は英語のネイティブスピーカーでしょ
日本語のネイティブスピーカー
みんなねみんなそのパティ部にですね知ってる単語の数がはるかにいつも使っている
単語よりは多いですね
だからその
言葉を勉強するときにですね単語を集まるときにそれが使える
段階になって
やっとその言葉をわかるしてるということであれば非常に少ない数の言葉しか集まら
ないです
それよりも
たくさん聴いたりたくさん読んだり
わざとそういう単語の表を勉強するんじゃなくて
できるだけたくさんの内容を聞いたり読んだりするとですね
自然的にその号4大阿仁増えるわけですよ
声が増えます
でその
大きな合意
それをそのそういう自然的な形
いわゆるターンさん聞いてたくさん読んでですね
場合によって使ってねそういう自然的な形をその単語を覚えるんであれば当然
たくさんたくさん聞かないといけない諏訪夏の勝ちですね
その言葉 line ゲージの言葉に慣れてくる言葉の勉強は慣れですから
慣れてくるとその動いを自然的に増えてくる
あのー
ターンをしている単語の数がどんどんどんどん多くなってくる
しかしそれはあくまで自然的な
その言葉を吸収した段階で過程においてその単語の風が増えてくるわけですよだから
しかしあのそしてそれだけたくさん聞いたり読んだりした場合それだけのその単語
わかるんであれば
割と早くそのそれを支えるそのその一部ですよ
全部じゃなくて白に必要な単語
必要な時に必要な単語
使えるようにはなるあるいは
自分が自信を持って使える単語を利用して
言いたいことは言えるいわゆる
コミュニケーションができるだから相手の言うことはまずわからないといけないで自分
が何かを言おうとした場合はやはり必要な単語
全部全部わかってる単語じゃなくてその意味を表す
ためにですね必要な単語わからず使えるようにはなりま
なります時間があのタッチとだから単語の数
いわゆるまあいえばパーシーブナ僕ら日和ですね
分かってる単語できるだけ多く増やしてやらないとダメなんですよねそう
いうあのたくさんの単語をわかってると使えなくてもいいからわかってるとそしてそれ
をたくさん聴いたりたくさん読んだり
通じてうんそういう単語を
いわゆるあの
集まった場合ですね吸収した場合ですね
その当駅であろうが
徒歩であろうが非常に良い成績や点数が出る
なぜかというと聞いたその内容はすぐわかる
何か読むときに単語を知ってるならば割と早く読める
そしてたくさん読んだたくさん聞いた経験があるとその読む
スピーディが速度が速くなんだから
スミてすぐわかる
聞いてすぐ分かるそしてそれだけたくさんが利いた沢山の単語をしてるんであれば
何がそのまあ映画英語の音
恒存何が自然的なにがただし
沿って正しくだけじゃなくてやり単語をですね
その
その自分がそれをた後正しく使うにはこの単語のこのための範囲
あのたくさん読んで聞いた中でですねそれだけの経験があるとその意味がね
その事象の解体3だけじゃなくてその
いわゆる範囲はどれくらいあるかとそしてどういう時に
使うべきがどういう他の端号と一生にですね
使うべきかそれはその
単にたくさん聴いたりたくさん読んだり
自然的に言葉いわゆる単語
集まるその基礎の上でやっとこれを正しく
自然的にネイティブの人に近い形に使えるようにはなります
だからこと
ばの勉強は言葉の勉強いわゆる
単語のプリキュアもちろんフレーズもありますしかしフレーズは単語のいわゆる
集まりなんですよだから単語知らないとそれいつも知れませんだからプレイズを勉強
するあるいは僕も人気でよく
フレーズも保存します勉強しますしかしそのフレーズの中の11のですね単語を知ら
ないとプレイ部は当然はいられません
まあ逆に単語知っててもですね
フレーズわからない場合もありますしかしそういえば続けて読めば
続けて木部聞けばですねそういうフレーズに何回も何回もぶつかってですね
場合によって調べて少しずつ6 please にも慣れて来くる
そしてフレーズを使い
ようにもなりますだから
繰り返していますと
何よりも単語
受け身でいい
受け身でもいい
あのぱしーばな合意をできるだけ増やしてください
増やしてそしてそれはいわゆるたドッグ課長って言いますか
たくさん読んでたくさん聞いて
あの機会があれば使おう
その言葉で話してる時に何もをすれず使えるもん
使ってみてあのどっか後かがあっても構わないからもう使ってみる
しかしキーそう基礎はですねやはり
単語合意それで今日は
まあもう一度繰り返しますけれども言葉の勉強は言葉じゃそういうことで
さよなら
[音楽]
ん
た
[音楽]
ん